what account to this video playing
Catwoman hmm can't a woman all in
capital letters and we get a catalan
early Quincy to wear okay can't play
that hmm I'd see how you're going to
play d4 or not not at the moment
hmm I tended to play Bishop to a 6 i'm
wondering something's some things it's a
bit off here mm round bad still game to
e 45 we are very complicated very
complicated position now in the center I
just forgot the line I have had studied
this years ago Queen a5 is the normal
booth hmm not sure about that one
it's always some very complicated
because of them this looks a post
opposing the Queen for both sides term
very tricky to play complaint g6 prevent
queena five Queen f5s always a bit of a
problem thus a'queen transferred to the
King side ok
oh really a 96 oops I forgot about Matty
sexy mm-hmm this is very very
embarrassing there cannot really take
with the 925
hmm
hmm Wow what about 96 okay I haven't
really wacky idea and that trying that
knight c6 I'm going to take and play
Bishop c5 could be could be an idea or
maybe takes you six and play Knight f2
ok sorry playing knight c6 as usual
completely frustrating frustrating
response and don't understand that b5
what are you doing now America's Got
please can go all the way up even up to
the 70 Bishop f hd7 but I can take with
a night though ok take F 67 while we're
looking all kinds of stuff in this game
really embarrassing now go there you ok
yeah cause he or she whatever could have
played 96 just winning easily this
shouldn't shouldn't be still running
this game okay I can try for a look at
five last resort yeah if i take here
what are you doing that luque one is
saying oh my check as always what one
trick left in each position every
position white resigned yeah what can
you say just a completely terrible game
by me and he just or she just just
blundered it away yeah this is a very
complicated position 95 him and I don't
know maybe I'm in trouble already it
looks it looks very shaky in the center
yeah my idea and quite amazed the
computer says it's it's a valid idea
after knight c6 I wanted to take no I
wanted to take and take here which is
not working due to this move all right
the idea is that this is in fact on IG
for whatever this is interesting with an
attack at least an attack
but ok as we saw it is not working you
to 94 but the computer is giving this
which I didn't see it all yeah that's
it's a pin it's a bin Wow here I'm just
winning but of course you don't need to
take computer gives best move look
everyone look everyone oh my no one's
going to play that in a blitz game Wow
yeah ok I also I don't know what I
should have a boy I probably would have
taken him maybe I can control her that
no it's always this is blood opinion
yeah I was just I was just completely
lost and then some white kid came to
this position where I'm i have this this
idea but i probably should should have
played them 97 first 97 first getting
this into the game but not immediately
playing it I need to block the deep on
the way it went down I'm just lost for
just easily lost yeah now every move
wins besides that one probably yeah just
am just very lucky alright thanks for
watching